you can crash it you will be fired here
trying to do everybody to Danone says
Dan and he's the key grip on the shoot a
really cool guy you gave us all like in
check don't the keep it go look at you
to tell you everything you want to learn
in these days into what college go to
youtube even if you want to be a super
dope rector go to this YouTube channel
right here we will learn all you need to
know about directing from this gentleman
right if you guys hear that anything
from a super dope director hell yeah
wait you didn't tell for the key
Griffith we helped with lighting
mystical lighting electric Africa Ellen
charted say she went above we're getting
[ __ ] but we really care about in July we
carve like the carmelite you make life
is natural like electrician is the
Gaborik they aim a light in an area and
we cultivated chop it shape it color it
soften it we make love to the light and
lay it down on people baby it's a little
bit intimidating what applies sounds
like a jet the quad is really cool but
honestly this is my favorite party look
at it oh my god
so yeah the giant quad we're going to
rely on this man this is our new guy
he's been working with like that for a
month now about now you're in California
you're at the world's largest electric
RC flying event and then you're going to
fly a gigantic mini one are you ready
there's trying to embarrass my dog I'm
like like yeah I think I'm ready
look at this way if you crash it you
will be fired yeah he's not wrong hahaha
we brought a couple extra props but I
don't think I'm gonna crash I'm gonna
take it really easy slide so much as it
just beat there to submission it's just
like will be here but I am beyond
excited see why I watch the video I want
to see it in person you're aided by this
thing you've never found the support
Cyrus or take it slow I've been a bit
nervous to me obviously if I tell myself
it's all fun and games
you know it's all fun and games there's
having fun our video was really really
cool but not nearly as cool as it is in
real life it's so intense
alright guys we're going to go a cam 35
BPM 135 crawls out me guys
yeah I remember doing good does he have
like the whole firm suit all the
jailhouse he's only brought me on the
shoulder and like the back and leg
all right love guys hey guys so we're
moving on to the fire - hear yourself
more about it once again so what's gonna
happen toys in the room we have various
you get the rubber cement on Allison
give me a set on camera once he does el
Aguirre line him up at that point we're
going to light up once he's lit Khmer
news video rock and roll there you go
he's lit i'ma say action so I'm going to
crawl out from the time I say action the
party's guys to be a 10-count for me on
my 10 count of yoga put a mouse will
have fight for month on combine two
cameras and two fire extinguishers we're
going to have our effects guy coming
inside there with a fire stickers and
they'll put them out no one steps in
incentives is clear so a burnt for 10
seconds if anything goes wrong and so
here something's wrong you know flap
Azar's we'll put it out in this bag I've
got the pieces to the drum that I built
last year but today we'll finish
building it I bought this before we went
to Dubai last year for the world's on
free and I never got around to finishing
this is a transmitter this is what
controls are drunk this is like
bare-bones Gillison I really hope I
brought all of the materials I need is
this a woman
this is called the burst copter v2 cos
very versatile this is actually a
home-built flight test drone they
designed it they modeled it and they
produce all the parts for me to buy and
build it's been so long since I've
tackled this I don't even really
remember what my problem with my cousin
had to do with this thing looks like I
figured
who else could better help me finish
putting this together than the guys who
actually designed and built well they're
like 5 years newer technology hoody it
ok I guess I don't have to keep laughing
at you vid is fun is Ellie all I've got
we're going to Capri view this exhibitor
before the Internet you didn't upgraded
we drove all the way up here so that I
can fly my drone at flight set now I
want to get it up in the sky and if I
can't get it built that's not going to
happen thank you for bringing all the
aircraft down we really don't like
shutting down the flight line but we
really appreciate your patience we are
going to have the gen I'm in equality
here the giant mini quad is very very
cool but it's also very very scary the
all-out weight is 30-some ish time I
should also mention that PJ is the only
one who's ever done it this will begins
first flight the hype is real right now
does it change anywhere you go
and he is up give it up for DN a trooper
[Music]
in spousal - going to try a manager here
[Music]
[Music]
down please
Roger take one a marker back okay ill
process okay yeah yeah okay here come
out where another body one more guess
talking luckily I am looks great it is a
fantastic jobs as well he is still
driving forward to throw anything else
the other way okay there yeah let's go
home for pricks in five minutes to the
region I will do began the book how good
that ain't good I use the pro tip from
ego
I shot a lot of fire if you are ever
filming fire for a video of any sort you
want to make sure it's not overexposed
on your camera go outside and point your
camera at the bluest sky and it goes for
the blue the same intensity the planes
how we did episode for the division and
getting old off from frame to her job
yeah
are made at the boneyard
this bar right here is made out of
material known as carbon fiber both in
the circle so magically indestructible
this thing can hit the ground at like
full speed and this will not break yeah
no [ __ ]
so Ian is the light has grown building
guru we took off these older hippies
that were a little bit out of date then
we install these new lumineer 30 fgfe we
got them soldered to the fork and now we
are going to install the flight
controllers then we are going to install
his receiver then we're going to plug it
into the computer and get everything
handled software wise ideally we'll
raise a client to that there's called
Paita place and you just want to update
it make sure it's all up today exactly
and then we will celebrate the motors on
them also make sure the motors saying
the right direction
ha
[Music]
[Music]
Hey nice work everybody
[Applause]
yeah winning over who's great
everybody's great job good fire still
burns beautiful fire we love it finished
lighting a guy on fire it's all done
actually seems over this is honestly one
of the more stressful things this week
that to deal with tomorrow and reading
nine pages of dialogue so fun day after
shooting nine more pages of dialogue and
then I have to shoot like them oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
like 30 cartwheels dude that was crazy
how it was so crazy I was at cute girls
caliber you are the next king dude oh
yeah it is a carbon-fiber prop you see
not unbreakable
well the props not broken is the
connector the whole thing is cars are
carbon fiber these are like $200 p.m.
use need for prop we have extra cost we
got this this one's gone double wedding
this one that one half what a crazy
crash I've never seen such a glorious
crash it's got a wood centre it's still
not unbreakable it's stronger than steel
you cannot miss out this is exactly what
I'm talking about these are the
carbon-fiber props on this thing and
they're not indestructible they are not
I got to know what happened sitting
there on the goggles doing my thing
coming around in a bank a nice turn
benefit of the job the videos where the
earthquake is going that's what I've
heard the gentleman had jello is very
intense so it's very hard to tell you
know just how high you are above the
ground and then it just kind of
conflicts and this is it like 30 car
wheel luckily only propellers broke yeah
the entire phrase totally intact so it
was chilling props we could fly it again
you're not getting fired
yeah he'll have time to do one set I'm
out of my seat
gotta be out here by 7:30 otherwise are
going to overtime you may have seen a
bunch of stuff about the ad pocalypse
and you know it's kind of challenge for
all YouTube creators these days so
thanks to you guys supporting us on
patreon like mr. Jordan Francis the rad
radish himself who got another awesome
supporters so Hawk fly I think I said
your name properly this time
I didn't last time any promise to stab
me in the chest with the samurai sword
which honestly was pretty sweet
now the supporter his name is John Welch
he's not associated with the grapes
company another guy who likes to support
us mr. James Bailey Ruby man last but
not least we also have mr. Richard
Blackburn is pretty sweet because I'm
soldering in a black wire it works
thank you Richard Blackburn you got me
to solder the black wire
[Music]